creating thumbnails can be
so overwhelming when you're just getting
started on youtube maybe
you don't have a background in graphic
design or photography or
you get really overwhelmed when it comes
to having to use
difficult editing software my name is
heather torres from think media and you
are watching the think marketing
live show i'm so excited because we're
going to be talking all about
thumbnails today and if you're watching
live
let me know where you're watching from
and if you're watching on the replay
let me know how many thumbnails have you
created
let's jump right into today's training
like i said
my name is heather torres and i am here
to help you build your influence
with video that's what we do at think we
are on a mission through
uh our youtube channels through social
media through our online trainings we
are on a mission to help
10 000 people create a full-time living
doing what they love and making an
impact on the world through the power of
video and i love these pictures because
this is showing some of our success
students
who are doing just that in all different
niches
we love to help creators entrepreneurs
small business owners authors speakers
anyone who wants to grow their influence
online
that's what think is here for and before
we get into today's training
i want to let you know that this live
stream is brought to you by
our brand new class that is think
master class this is where you can go
and learn everything you want to know
about how to win
on youtube this year now when i say
everything you need to know
you actually only need to know one
strategy and that's what
the founder and ceo of think media and
think marketing
teaches you on this free class i'll tell
you more about that at the end but
let's jump into thumbnails now what is a
thumbnail i'm sure you know right you're
watching a youtube video
you probably saw my thumbnail and you
clicked on this video because
you want to learn how to make better
thumbnails and make them quick
and easy and let me give you a little
background
i do not know how to use photoshop i
do not know how to use fancy editing
software i
do not have a background in graphic
design or even in
photography but i made this graphic
right here all on
a simple software now this isn't
necessarily a thumbnail
but i'm going to show you exactly how i
did this we're going to do
like kind of behind the scenes on this
video and i'm going to share with you
my favorite site for making thumbnails
but what is
a thumbnail well a thumbnail it's a
visual image
to support the title and topic
of the video that is the job of a
thumbnail it's actually
not supposed to be the piece that sells
the video
it's supposed to be the supporting
element of both the title
and the big key the topic of the video
that you're doing so when you think
about your thumbnail you want it to be
supportive not the main piece but the
supportive you know it's kind of like
when you go to in and out you get you
get the burger don't you you get i love
the double double i don't do cheese on
it i love the double double and i just
learned that you cannot get a bun you
can get lettuce
mind blown but i love that part about in
and out
and the best part about in and out
the french fries don't you think the
french fries are the best part about in
and out
and those are the supportive element of
the burger and that's what a thumbnail
is for so i'm going to give you an image
here this
is an image of different thumbnails
that were made on a very simple software
i personally think that these thumbnails
are eye-catching
they're colorful they're simple right
there's a lot of different pieces and
elements
wrapped into these four thumbnails and
i'll have you know that three of these
thumbnails were actually
just taken from stock images i'm going
to show you exactly how you can find
this information and that is with a a
well-known website called
canva.com let me know in the comment
section have you gone to canva.com
before have you
played around on canva.com if you
haven't your world is about to change
canva.com is such a uh a
it's such a great piece of software to
have in your back
pocket for all things creating online
now
you might be saying okay heather but is
canva.com free that's always the go-to
question and yeah
there are free options on canva.com but
when you think about canva.com and what
it can do for your business right
remember
if you're on youtube if you're making
youtube videos you
are in business you might not be making
any money but going into this with the
mindset
of a business owner what do business
owners do
they invest in their business they
invest in the tools and software's that
they need and so
uh i recommend actually upgrading into
what's called the pro account
it's it's 12.95 a month if that's just
you know uh
three starbucks coffees that you don't
have that month it's well worth it
for your channel so that gets uh the
idea of should i do the free or should i
do the pro i'm gonna be teaching you off
of the pro account
i do pay 12.95 out of my own money so
that i can use
canva.com so when you are doing
canva.com
um i want to show you the the second
site that i would recommend that
actually is free and we're going to use
both of these today
during this uh live training is
unsplash.com type that out
unsplash.com this is a site where you
can get
uh great beautiful images
to be able to create beautiful
thumbnails because
here's my hack my hack is is that you
actually don't have to take pictures of
yourself
if you're like me you're like i mean i
look at this background this is not the
best background i mean it's
it's pretty for video but it's not
really good for actually
using thumbnail design and so one of the
hacks is that you
don't actually have to have pictures of
the things
that you're talking about i know
mind-blown
so i'm going to teach you how you can
make beautiful thumbnails without
actually having to take
photos and yes people in photos are
great but did you know you can succeed
on youtube without
ever showing your face in a thumbnail
did you know that you can make
beautiful thumbnails without ever having
to be the subject
of the picture in the thumbnail you can
do this and i'm going to show you
exactly how
in this training so unsplash.com
unsplash.comcanva.com those are the two
that you need now are there other
websites you can use
absolutely there are but today we're
just gonna be covering these two and in
future trainings i will definitely show
you some
other sites that we use for other things
so
here's a cute uh let's go actually i'm
gonna just pull this up i want to shout
out
i see daniel's here on the live stream i
see that fire over 50 is here on the
live stream thank you so much for being
here i'm actually just gonna
we're gonna do this together i'm gonna
pull up the website and we're gonna go
right to canva.com
and i'm going to show you a little bit
around the site and i'll show you some
cool things
that i do on this site so i'm going to
stop the screen share i'm going to add
the screen share we're going to go right
over to canva.com
first off when you see canva.com guys if
you see what we're doing on instagram if
you see what we're doing on linkedin
some of our advertising it's all coming
from this
site now what i love is you can go right
up here and you just type in
youtube thumbnail and when you type in
youtube thumbnail what's really cool is
it actually gives you these different
options
uh where you can see it says like you
can do travel or beauty or
food or music you have all these options
but you can click right on youtube
thumbnail
and it's gonna give you all of these
beautiful options
that you can start making thumbnails
with i love this because it's really
great templates and you'll notice their
photography is
beautiful but maybe you're like well i
mean heather i'm doing a vegan cooking
channel
like tony from the think media team
him and his wife cami they have a
cooking channel now tony is a
amazing photographer but if i were to be
starting a vegan channel right now i
wouldn't be able to make
that type of photography so you could go
here you go to
photos and the reason that i love
canva.com is because they have
a wide range of photos now you'll see
here i've already
practiced this live stream before i went
live and so i'm going to click on
vegan now what does it bring up it
brings up a ton
of images i can use and here's what i'm
looking for
i'm looking for an image like this one
why am i looking for an image like this
well because it gives me some space over
on the side
to actually add some text so i would
actually be
taking this text moving it here and
saying something like
let's see vegan let's type correctly
heather
for beginners now i can change the color
of this
i'm just using a standard font that we
use here at think media
and think marketing just a very simple
font that you can use
and voila look i now have a thumbnail
vegans for beginners i can spruce this
up i can maybe make this cool effect on
here
i can change the intensity of that i've
got a lot of different options of what i
can do to the text
there's all these different text
templates that they have
but guys are you seeing the power of
this like i could have a vegan channel
talking about vegans for beginners i
don't have to be in the thumbnail
and i'm using these stock photos right
from the platform look at how beautiful
this
is i would when you're looking in the
feed inside of youtube
most people click on pretty
thumbnails i mean let's just be real and
say it straight
most people click on pretty thumbnails
they're unique
they're clean they have bright colors
simple text
maybe something's popping out there's
some dynamics to
what happens in a thumbnail and so
this is just one example of how you
could use canva.com now
here's a cool hack if you want to hack
on canva
type in the word hack right now in the
live stream i want to see
hack in the live stream if you want to
see a really cool hack
that you can do on canva.com
and i want to just quickly give a shout
out again i love seeing the people who
are showing up for these live streams
they happen
every single week here either the think
marketing show or
coffee with kennel thank you so much for
being here all right i'm starting to see
hack jim said hack
tina said hack okay we've got hack
happening okay good so i'm gonna show
you a really cool hack
now have you ever wondered how
you can just cut someone out of the
image like if i were to take a photo
right now
and i wanted to like cut that out and
get rid of my background
you can do this in canva.com now i don't
know if you saw this really cool update
that they did at canva.com
you can do this so here's how you do
this i'm going to just take an image
here's just an image that i
upload it's just me wow look at that
look at that heather right there
wow now here's what i'm going to do i'm
going to click this button that says
effect when i click effect it says
background
remover now i want to get rid of this
blue background because i want to change
this thumbnail so it's going to just do
a little did
do a little dance just going to give me
that piece bam
there is heather without the background
now if i'm gonna do a thumbnail
i don't want heather to be this big
right when you're doing a thumbnail
you want to do him you want the subject
because it's small
think about looking at on my phone you
want to be
larger on your thumbnail so i would
actually make myself about
yay big on a thumbnail now i need a cool
background
right because white isn't a great
background look at what canva.com gives
you
so many background options why don't we
look in here and let's do
purple oh i like purple okay so let's do
purple and then let's go here and say
what's the best thumbnail heather is
awesome that is the best thumbnail of
the day
no just kidding um let's do how about
youtube
for beginners okay so that's gonna be my
thumbnail
i'm obviously going very quickly just to
give you an idea of what you could do
right so these are just some images that
you could use
but isn't that awesome i just made a
super cool thumbnail
i removed the background and then all of
a sudden i put a new background on there
and now look at how
clean that image is now all of the
images that i showed you
at the beginning that was all of those
thumbnails
those were from canva.com
uh here again i'm in photos i'm going to
go to photos and let's say i want to do
like um gifs because i'm going to be
doing a gift guide
oh this is a good one here or maybe i
would choose this guy
why am i choosing this one remember it
has i got to get rid of all my layers
now
this is giant heather um i would choose
this one
because it's got room over here on the
side
for the text now that is a uh
just one hack that you can do now let's
go to unsplash maybe
you um are doing uh
maybe okay let's do this we use this
image
in one of our thumbnails this is the
exact image that we use
look how cool that image is and we did
it for our premiere pro
tutorial we used this exact image from
unsplash and we just
all you need to do is credit the person
in your description
you could use this image here for social
media i mean there's so many options
when you go to unsplash.com so i want to
bring
back on really quick my notes because i
want to show you
my screen share so that you can see the
notes again
and i'm going to pull this back up did
you guys like that kind
of training where i just kind of show
you behind the scenes okay remember
let's go here
let's scroll here camp by canva canva
awesome okay here's some tips for you
here's some tips for you
here's what you want to make sure you
want to make sure you have fewer words
in your thumbnail than you have in your
title
you want it to be supportive remember
that it's a supportive
part of the whole piece that you need
to win on youtube you need the title you
need the
topic you need the thumbnail you need
all three of those things to work in
holistically in order to make sure that
your video
gets clicked on so you want fewer words
you want a
clear image a clear image
wins remember that write that down a
clear
image wins that's why i and i wanted to
change that background of
of blue maybe i was standing outside and
i wanted to remove the background
because i just want a
clear image of what i'm trying to show
you can get that image from unsplash.com
or you can get that image
on canva when you're paying for the pro
account
and the last thing is color matters
color
matters remember that if you see this
one here i got this
i made this exact image on canva the
color
pops it's blue it's bright now remember
when you're making
different thumbnails you can either go
with a thumbnail
theme right maybe you have a coloring
branding theme
but you when someone is on their phone
remember
you want to be the one that stops
the scroll that's what you want to say
so when i'm scrolling through
what i'm seeing on mine wow look at that
oh there's mine right there
so it's nice and blue it's nice and big
and so thinking about when you're
scrolling through what are you seeing
you want yours to be colorful you want
yours to be
um uh very distinct so that you can see
there
i see this image this question right
here how did you cut shawn out like that
i just showed it so make sure you watch
the replay there's an effect that you
can do inside of canva.com well hey
i hope that that was a powerful tip for
you uh to get started with thumbnails we
have additional thumbnail training
coming here on the think marketing live
show
as well as over in our think media
youtube
channel so you're going to want to make
sure that you are watching and
subscribed both here
and on think media and after this
training
if you've not yet signed up for our one
hour free
youtube masterclass then that would be
your next step you want to learn the
three secrets to youtube success
that are working this year youtube has
changed
this year and we want to teach you the
new rules to success
on youtube so you're gonna so go and
register
at thinkmasterclass.com
now i'm looking forward to taking some
of your questions we're gonna go right
into
the live q a part of today's training
but before we do that
check out this quick video are you ready
to start
or grow your youtube channel do you feel
stuck
and need help connecting the dots join
this free web class where you'll learn
the step-by-step playbook for youtube
success
we've helped thousands of purpose-driven
entrepreneurs
just like you grow their influence with
video
register today for this exclusive
training at think thinkmasterclass.com
all right well thank you so much for the
comments i love that i'm seeing some
regulars in the comments and we're going
to jump into
the q a the live q a part of today
take a quick sip of water if you've got
some water nearby
all right and it looks like in the
studio we have brian brian's gonna come
on first
hey ryan how you doing hi heather i'm
doing well thank you very much
great tell everyone who you are what
your channel is about and how i can help
you today
my name is brian hostick i am uh the
motley mix
merchant on youtube um i am a
ebay reseller and thrifter so i go to
auctions and thrift stores and find
things to resell on ebay usually
and uh the channel is doing well 200
subscribers right now slowly slowly
growing
um but my question to you is regarding
thumbnails
i'm not quite a celebrity yet but since
i started i've been using just my face
usually holding one of my items in the
thumbnail should i continue to do that
using my face like you do with sean most
of the time
or is it better to use just stock photos
from the start until you actually are
say a celebrity that kind of thing
really great question and i'm just
pulling this up because i want to show
everyone this
example um so your question is do i use
my face
or do i use a stock image so a couple
things
if you're doing resell um actually
me i would actually suggest going to
here on youtube
on skillshare or on udemy taking a
course of
product based photography because if
you're doing reselling if
are you are you trying to resell through
youtube or are you just talking about
resale okay
what i've thrifted and what i've sold
perfect then actually
i would use um i would use stock images
that's fine you can use stock images you
can
you can sprinkle your face in there and
i wanted to bring uh even just
what we do over on think media up
because over on think media
we really do multiple ways of um
of doing uh thumbnails it's not just
one specific way like this one has nolan
in the image but if you go down here
this versus video
is actually just a stock image i mean
it's a stock image we created
but you'll see that you can do both like
you can do just the images
um i would recommend too that if you're
trying to build a
high um a high quality brand
that actually using beautiful stock
imagery and having the words
speak to what you're teaching could be
really
uh a good direction to go when creating
youtube thumbnails i have mixed it up a
little bit some of my tutorial type
videos i've used stock photos or
other photos of my own that i put on the
screen but most of the stuff on my
weekly stuff with its
thrifting and or what sold on ebay kind
of thing i've been using my face
or just myself holding one of the items
that kind of thing with i try to do a
catchy thing beside my face
that doesn't uh exactly mirror the title
so that it leads them to the title kind
of what was your channel again i want to
type it in
it's called motley mix merchant
merchant there we go all right let's see
i must have spelled it wrong let me go
in here i'm going to share my screen
again and make sure i'm doing this right
did i spell this right motley
mix l-e-y m-o-t-l-e-y
now in all of your videos are you um
there we go okay cool so let's see here
what you're doing okay so here let's
give you some ice
um okay what i would actually do is just
cut out the background
so i like these even if the background's
cut out because
i didn't know about that feature i've
used canva all the time and i didn't
know about that feature of getting rid
of definitely
pointed out today that's great because
this yeah that'll be great for you
because when you go into here you can
take that image and you can cut that
background out and it could be just you
and that
in the uh mickey mouse or you know yeah
so i think
using that hack would be a good uh a
good feature for you
definitely yeah awesome well hey i'm
really excited for you getting your
channel started
um loving that you are uploading i'm
seeing consistent uploads so
congratulations on that
and i can't wait to see what the future
holds for you great thank you very much
thanks for being on today i love that
brian
um he got started he i can look at his
channel right now i can see you know
he's getting
41 views on the video yesterday so
really cool and what a really fun niche
to be in because
man the reseller niche is a hot
niche so really excited about that i'm
going to look really quick at what his
best video is i didn't show anyone that
and i want to see what his
best video is and would you look at that
if you even just look at what's working
brian
your best video is your best two videos
actually don't have your face in them so
it's never
a way of thinking oh man what about you
know should i look like this or should i
do this
he's a reseller and he's saying from
this to this
you can already see that that is a
really great thing and then this one
over here
two different top videos i'm on his
youtube page i went to sort by
and we're just gonna look at what the
numbers are telling us and the numbers
are telling us
that in what he's producing his two top
videos
are thumbnails without his face in them
so
hope that helps you and encourages you
brian thank you so much for being a part
of the think fam
and we are going to jump into the next
person which is going to be
aiden and aiden is one of our think
super fans how you doing aiden good how
are you
good what can i help you with today tell
everyone who you are what your channel's
about
and how i can help you today yes so my
name is aiden
and i'm from media with aiden on youtube
and i do tech and entrepreneurship to
help
you go further faster in media with
photo and video
amazing sounds like a little think media
family member so
love it aiden uh what question can i
help you with today
yeah so um i'm trying to get my view
duration to go up so more people
want to watch my videos for a longer
amount of time
because the people who are have been
able to grow their channel and want to
become my clients
so my question is how can i
make attractive youtube videos
um to boost up my view duration and just
my analytics in general
yeah really great question so uh aiden's
really great
one first one i congratulate you aiden
i'm seeing the leveling up of the
thumbnail game happening so really great
job on that
um so your your question is how do i get
people to watch
more right how do i get people to stay
on how do i increase that
so a couple things i want to suggest you
one is to make
series of videos meaning rather than
choosing
the topic to be just a one-time topic
make a video a two-parter so that
they've watched
one part they're gonna watch all the way
through and they're gonna watch part two
so that's a way
to increase your view duration the
second way well actually the first way
that would be considered the second way
the first way you know i'm gonna tell
you
you've got to be bringing great value to
your audience so it's got to be
something that is searchable
and that people are actually interested
in and i would actually suggest aiden i
know you have a lot of skills
at such a young age i would actually
want to move you towards what i would
call
a utilitarian meaning someone who is
teaching how to use a tool and i want
everyone to write this down because this
is a really
clear uh piece of advice if you're
trying to break through
on youtube you want to be known for
helping people solve a problem and i
know you solve a lot of problems aided
when it comes to media and what that
looks like
so i would actually pick a piece of
software that you know how to use
it could be on your phone it could be um
on a tablet it can be on the computer
and i want you to become the expert of
that product it could be canva.com
tutorials
literally the tutorial i just did aiden
you could be doing those exact things
all the time how to take the background
out
of a picture do that to do that video
right
and how are you going to increase your
view duration
you're teaching someone something where
they have to watch
from the beginning to the end right
because they want to learn how to do the
whole thing
so when you think about what you could
be doing uh to increase
view duration how you can get people to
watch videos longer
is you want to say i'm going to share
with you the five steps on how to do
this
when i know i'm gonna learn five steps i
wanna stick around because i wanna learn
all five steps okay so those are three
ways that you can do that let's recap
number one
i want you to bring massive value to
your audience i see you're doing that
right now
because i've watched some of your videos
and i know that you really are sticking
below that like 10 minute mark to give
good content
so that's number one number two become
utilitarian
pick a piece of software pick something
where you can
teach how to use it because people want
to learn how to do that
number three you want to uh
teach things in parts so part one and
part two keeps people watching
and number four is i want you to be
making
the video and say i'm going to teach you
the three steps
i'm going to teach you the 10 steps
whatever that looks like
because then they want to stick around
and i don't want you to waste people's
time at the beginning
the worst type of tutorials are the ones
that waste people's time at the
beginning
they skip it they want to go to the next
thing so be the person who
helps people learn how to do something
awesome aiden
awesome thank you so much that was so
much value i have one question though
i'm here for it so um if i were to make
a
series i was watching like you guys made
a part two series
on like youtube strategies and stuff on
the one youtube strategy
would you almost want me to only because
for some videos i'm giving
10 tips or like 15 tips and stuff like
that should i break it up where it's
five tips for
per video then put some details in there
with the
tips that's how you do it exactly yeah
okay thank you so much
awesome aiden hey have a great holiday
and i'm so grateful for you for showing
up all the time
i want to send you a think media shirt
for the holidays so i'll make sure that
you get with tony or melissa
and we want to send you a think shirt so
when you come on next time i want to see
that swag okay
oh i will do because you guys are the
best people in the world
thanks aiden oh man young entrepreneurs
aiden is just i love it he's always here
always hustling um if you want to get
hooked up with a young
uh a young media guy that's who you want
to go to all right let's see who else we
have
super excited for the people who are
here today
and let's see um it looks like i've got
uh uh uh
[Music]
vashna is here hey how you doing
i'm doing good first of all like how can
i top
that he's he's just amazing i just
wanted to say that
he he's like he's living it up and he's
only like 10 or 11.
he's an inspiration for her i'm like i
want to meet his parents and shake their
hand and say great job
yeah yeah well hey i know we talked a
little while ago tell everyone who you
are
what you do and how i can help you today
so
to those who are watching hi my name is
handmade by vaishna
and i do arts and college content mainly
but i
do a little bit of lifestyle i try to
center my content around like
really my how my life is right now so
it's like easier for me to
like create since i'm a student
um but i'm trying to push out more and
more art content because
i feel like if i remain consistent with
one main niche then it will really help
me grow and i've definitely been seeing
that
mm-hmm and what how can i find you on
youtube
um for now um i haven't really changed
my
youtube name yet but if you do search up
handmade by vaishna
i belie no no yeah i mean by vaishna i
believe i do come up
yeah this is you right
yeah that is me great so how can i help
you today
um so as you can see my product
um like uh thumbnails are doing i guess
okay like the ones where i show like oh
this is my card or like
10 supplies and some of the ones where
i'm also in it are good but
um as you can see i only have one
background and this is like the best
lighting i can get in the house i was
just wondering how can i change up
my my thumbnails to make them a little
more appealing
and also how can i showcase my products
in a
i guess more appealing way yeah really
great question so
um so first one uh number one um
do you have a smartphone yes
there we go all right so here's the
first thing i need you to invest in if
you don't have it already
is a tripod okay so i want you to invest
in a tripod it could be
a 20 tripod definitely search on uh
think media maybe tony can drop a link
to
or alina from the think team can drop a
link to some of the ones that we have
i'd show you the one i'm using it's a
joby but my webcam is on it right now so
i can't show it to you
um so tripods one because that can help
you move around to take better photos
right
i want you to get into a space that has
a clear background so when i first
started creating
thumbnails i would actually just take
them on a white
wall now here's a tip though you don't
want to be right
on the wall you want to give some depth
between you
and the wall okay and the reason for
that is because
if you're right on the wall you're going
to have that little like
shadow that kind of happens when you're
you know when something's right on a
wall
so you want to step away from the wall a
little bit and you can take it on a
blank colored wall
i take pictures of my kids outside on
our garage
because it's just a blank canvas
basically
and i do it outside because i then get
natural
lighting so that's the other thing is
you want to make sure you've got good
lighting
i love the expression that you're doing
in your face too like
this one here really good i love that um
and so that so two so the tip number
three is good expression in your face so
really good
but you're moving that out of the way so
um that would be how i would kind of get
better
photography uh on making good thumbnails
and we actually
have a really great um youtube video
that i'll make sure it gets dropped in
the links and it'll be in the
description below
that does actually help you with
thumbnail photography omar from the
think team who is a
world-class photographer breaks down
some of his tips that way too
so so make sure to watch that one so
that's how you do
uh um getting you in other locations
because
i love what you are doing with the idea
here like if i see this one here i see
that beautiful
uh can canvas behind you is that what it
is or
what are those called thomas tree what's
happening yeah we go from amazon
right but now i'm going to critique you
because i'm your coach here when i look
at it though
it's the colors are all kind of the same
they're that like pinky color
right yeah so i would do a contrasting
color
so i would google the color wheel i want
everyone to do this
google the color wheel because you want
to have an opposite color
so that it stands out with that color so
that's a tip just for your text
on that image now you can actually go
back if you wanted to
you could change that whole image on
canva
and actually remove the background and
could put a cool new background on there
so that is an
option as well if you if you're feeling
that now i know you are an artist and
you're doing
product based photography so my
challenge to you
is to watch five videos this weekend
on how to do product based photography
and here's what they're going to teach
you
you want to make sure i love this i can
tell already this is really great
because
you're doing it on a clean surface i can
see the wood behind there
it's very clean i love the arrow i mean
this is just a great photo so i would
say
you are doing it you're on the right
track already from the last time we
talked
to now i'm seeing a vast improvement
even in what you're doing
so congratulations to that i would uh
really
watch those five videos on best
product based photography and tony from
the think team
he's had to watch a ton of videos on
food based photography because that's
totally different
than human based photography right so
you want to be thinking about if i'm
selling a product
i need to know how to film this i need
to know how to do really good
photography with this
and so i love this this layout that
you've got i like
all the colors in this one um just
looking over the video i can sell
like this is beautiful you're doing a
great job so
this one here five-minute crafts even
that image there is probably a better
image
than this one of you holding it but
it'll probably be something
like this simple you can order on amazon
these um uh paper that looks like
slate and stone and marble
and um wood and they're just pieces of
paper
and then what you can do is you can go
to the dollar store and you can get
those white you know when you make those
presentations in school and they're like
those white
boards that it's regular board and then
two boards on the side
you put that piece of paper and you put
that white board there
and the light then starts to reflect off
of it so that'll help you with
even those beautiful cards that you're
making be able to showcase the art that
you're doing so
super excited that you're here did those
tips help you
yes they definitely did um also one more
question
um would you recommend that instead of
having like
you know like like the plain tapestry
that i have like that
invest in those like roles that you
always see
in like the youtube videos and then like
just like switch them out yes the paper
rolls are amazing we actually just used
them in one of our sets that we just did
um you can get those paper rolls on
amazon we actually have
a video over on think media of how to
make
the backdrop now it is a little bit more
advanced in
um in the uh way that omar does it
on his video but what's really great is
you can get this youtube studio idea
right here he's using
the the paper in the background on these
ones see this this is all this paper
that we just roll out and we have
different colors in the background so
if you're doing your face photography
this is an option as well
you just want to make sure that you've
got great lighting so if you've not
invested in lighting that would be your
next investment
to make because what makes a great photo
is great
lighting awesome hey thank you so much
fashion for being on today
super excited for what is to come for
you and we will see you on the next
coffee or what are we on we're on think
marketing
live i had to think about what show i
want
this is what happens when you work at
think you're just all over thanks for
being on today
wow well i hope that helped you um we're
gonna make sure that all
of the suggestions i'm giving are linked
down below so we'll have amazon links to
those
uh different pieces of paper that i
talked about the ones that uh
vashna just said with the roles that you
could do um i was
giving the suggestion that at the dollar
store you can go get those white pieces
of paper
but hear me friends you should be
studying
what you need to improve on so if you
are trying to take
product-based photography do that
on youtube or go to skillshare or udemy
and really invest some time
into leveling up your photography if you
are not going to use
stock photos remember that stock photos
is a great way that you can do that
and that's what i shared here on the
show all right we've got
let's see um we've got
n man hey hey how you doing
good good tell everyone who you are what
your channel's about and how i can help
you today
well just remind you my name is inman
slimer
i'm a talk show host over on youtube
which actually do
i am getting ready for episode 4 right
now because
uh it will be up before the new year's
episode that which is on our way to
season two
and so yeah my question today is since
i'm starting using adobe spark
uh my question is does adobe spark
make thumbnails really great question
you know what i'm gonna have to search
that up right now because
i actually have not tested i personally
have not tested
adobe spark so let's actually look this
up together family because
i'm not going to answer it if i don't
know it so adobe so here's how i do this
does actually i'm going to do this for
you because this is how i look up
everything right this is how i learn all
the things
does adobe spark make thumbnails
yes let's see
youtube thumbnails made with adobe spark
there you go right there looks like you
got your answer
how to make youtube thumbnails with
adobe spark awesome
so hey i uh i challenge you to go over
there and watch
these five videos and you know what i
love here
i can see this one right here that is a
stock photo
look at that everyone just proven my
point that you can use stock photography
when making images that's another stock
photo so
i would go over there and man and get
started on learning how to use adobe
spark
got it awesome thanks for being on today
thanks
hey guys you know what i built a whole
business learning from the youtube
search bar let's be real that's what i
did
that means that you can do it too there
are amazing people
and here is another tip i don't know if
you
just saw what i did there i don't know
if you just saw what i did there
i asked a question
in the youtube search bar
i needed an answer to a question
and these creators answered
my question why is that important
that's important because if you're
trying to grow an audience on youtube
if you know that you want to reach
someone and help them do something
that you've got to be answering their
questions i had no idea
if adobe spark made thumbnails i was a
student
i had a problem i came to the youtube
search bar
and this these creators answered
my question so if you're making content
on youtube
i want you to answer specific questions
now i just want to just really highlight
this first one here
look at how beautiful that thumbnail is
this thumbnail gets an a
plus why let's go over the things we
learned today
it's got a clean background number one
we got a clean background number
two it's supportive words on the
thumbnail remember a thumbnail
is supportive to the title and the topic
and then number three
it's got some color that blue and the
white really stand out
and look at his face he's got great
facial expression
he's got his head is large and that
feels
awkward when you're first starting out
on youtube but
hear me friends i can see his eyes i can
see his smile
i can see he's pointing and there's not
a lot of room
around him which means that my eyes go
directly to what he is showing me
this is an a plus thumbnail a
plus thumbnail and i don't even know
this person so
claudio you win today's prize
of a plus thumbnails all right i've got
a couple more people
coming up next and um tony's in the
background helping me out amber's gonna
come on next
tony and uh then you can tell me who's
next after that
all right we're remember on let me
unshare my screen
hi amber how you doing good how are you
good tell us who you are
what your channel's about and your
question for today so
i am amber may nelson that is my channel
and it's about um
healthy tips tricks and then i have some
vlogs on there
so i lost 100 pounds and then became an
athlete so i'm
trying to event i actually started my
channel to
uh do some of my psychology stuff i'm a
phd student
and then it kept evolving i've only been
on for about two months
um so my thumbnails have also
evolved a lot um and so i'm kind of like
consistency the whole just doing a face
is hard for me
i feel like it's too boring when i look
at other people doing like weight loss
stuff
there's a lot of before and after which
i have
like on some of my pictures but i
obviously can't just do that
like every time i do a weight loss or
like health related video
um so i'm just kind of like trying to
find out i don't know like i like being
a part of my pictures i really like my
thumbnails that i have on some of my
vlogs where it has a lot of stuff from
the video in it i do have canva
um that's where i make my stuff and so i
i just kind of
yeah i don't know i do when i look at
other people that are
really um like i guess really big in
my world like what i'm doing
um i i look at their thumbnails a lot
and try to do similar
things but like you can see where my
thumbnails are older
and then the very oldest ones i actually
redid those recently
but then i felt like those were too
boring those ones these ones down here
these like pink ones
okay i don't like those so i'm having as
you can see i have a lot of variety
um and i i need to get it nailed down
but i
want it to like represent me and i don't
want it just to be like
a face for me i feel like for mine
specifically i feel like just a face
with words
isn't it isn't going to do the trick i
guess
um but but maybe maybe it will i don't
know
yeah because what you're saying is here
um i i first off
amber i want to say congratulations i
mean for all the things like can we just
congratulate you for that i don't know
if anyone
tells you how amazing that is but what
an
incredible thing to do to not only
transform your life but now want to gift
that to others
that is a beautiful thing and so i want
to just honor you as a creator
as a woman who stepped out to walk
through this journey
thank you so much for bringing that
content online so because your
experience
is going to be so unique to other
people's experiences you might be
talking about the same things but you
are coming at it from your own
perspective and that's what youtube
needs so very excited about uh about
that now
i want to also say a couple things
you've been
you've been on the platform now for two
months is that right yeah
so you're just getting started and so
you're in this first
year where it's all about experimenting
so
some of your thumbnails could look one
way one time another way another time
and that's perfectly fine
so i just want to give you kind of the
permission and the grace to say
experiment away you're in the
experimenting phase
and it doesn't have to be branded and
perfect
and all of those things right now it's
building the muscle
of creating the content so
what i'm doing is your question really
is how do i like
this the just your head or what does
that look like how can i make good
good thumbnails um one i love how you
said you were studying other people
that's a really great way to just see in
your niche
are other people making similar types of
thumbnails
um this one here one thing i would say
like even when i just see that
i would actually say if i were to go
here and go like before
and after weight loss
women let me just show you what comes up
so like
okay not that okay like this one here
when i see this one let me go back let
me see if it gives me the image
that is like big yeah like
how big big the image is and i can see
i'm seeing a 145 pound transformation
she's got 13 million views on this video
by the way like yeah
what else what i don't get any views and
it makes me so
frustrated because i'm just like not
coming up but yeah i see what you're
saying like it's
um where's them there was one that i had
like my most
recent video i pretty much almost copied
another girls who was way up there i
don't know if she'll be on this page but
um yeah a lot of them are just pictures
with no
yeah no words seeing that okay exactly
and that's what we do here at think
media we're not creating an isolation
we are creating off of what we see works
how do we know what works we're seeing
the numbers so one thing here when it
says like how to lose weight and get fit
that to me is such a large that is a
large pool that you're jumping into
but how i lost 100 pounds or 100 pound
weight loss
transformation that actually is not as
large of a pool
but that is something that someone would
want to see
right like someone in that position so
the even the positioning of the video
is what i would maybe work on also
because how to lose weight and get fit
is a huge pool that you're jumping into
right like i've changed my titles like
800 times
okay so here's something really
interesting here's what i did i'm just
typing this in here
how to lose 100 and then first thing
that comes up is pounds
now how long did it take you to lose a
hundred pounds
a year okay so how to lose a hundred
pounds
in in a year that is actually something
people are searching
and look at this two years ago like what
are we learning from her look at what
we're learning from her thumbnail right
away
what do you see tell me what you see
amber yeah the exact word how i lost 100
pounds in
a year before and after right i'm seeing
that on there
yep so this is how i would so you're
you're headed in the right direction and
just because you made this video
hear me amber you can make this video
five more times
yeah so if you go down i have one that
was a little more similar to the one
that you showed or i guess it's not on
that page
but i have one that was more um similar
my
initial like intro i don't know why all
my videos aren't showing up
i'll find it it was like yeah it was
like my initial story and it's a much
bolder it has my face and then it has
two
is that all my videos that are showing
no i think i'm in uploads
i gotta go back here yeah i was gonna
say because yeah i have one really
similar that was like my first
video when i talked about um
my weight loss and um i had done
yeah like a really a bigger um
more similar to what you just said so
but and it said like
my 100 pound and stuff like that and it
wasn't as broad but it still
didn't seem to do very well so no
worries
remake the video remake the thumbnail
redo a new spin on it do a different
title
on it right like you've made the content
but if that's the
target audience you're trying to reach
be thinking about
the things that she is searching for she
may be searching for
the best walking shoes for overweight
females
she may be certain likely does that make
sense like it doesn't necessarily have
to be
that piece that you're doing and so if
we just take this all the way back to
the first question about the thumbnails
and what that looks like
i want you to just be studying the other
thumbnails just like we just did
and i want you to put your own spin on
them and
experiment with not just your face like
you said but experiment with
um stock photos experiment just just
experiment this whole year
don't let any of these pieces feel like
shoot did i do it wrong is this
is you know what happened here every
uploaded video that we do on
on think marketing is a test and that's
how we look at it this
is a test we're gonna put it out there
then we're gonna evaluate it and then
we're going to see what happens from
there but i just again
i just want to encourage you that you're
on this journey it's a marathon not a
sprint
and over time you're going to figure out
what works for you you're going to
figure out what your audience is
attracted to you're going to figure
out what your message is in that market
you're going to figure out wow when i
talk about this
topic all of a sudden people are just
gravitating towards it and i wouldn't
even thought that was it right like you
just got to keep creating
and that'll help you grow gotcha thank
you so much
oh thank you so much for being a part of
the community bye
bye amber wow wow wow well hey
we are going to jump into alex is coming
on to the
think marketing live show alex how you
doing
i'm good how are you good good hey tell
us who you are
where you're watching from and what
question i can help you with
well with the standing seam channel um
it's what i do for a profession
um it's a it's a type of metal roofing
that
is very kind of niched and
it's uh it needs more exposure
i don't have a i don't have a ton of
videos up but um
i guess what my my question i'm watching
from or
i'm i'm here in ontario canada that's
where i'm broadcasting from
so um i guess yeah my question
uh to tony and to you to you the team
there
is um you know there's like my market
i've there's a few uh channels doing
this thing right now
um they're not as niched down
but there is uh
you know they're just getting they're
getting massive views and i know i know
i'm new but i just want to know like
how you know i want to steer this ship i
don't want to you know
waste a bunch of time and you know go
down a
path but i'm really passionate about
this stuff so
and i've been i've been doing it for a
long time so i bring a lot
i bring a lot to the table so you know i
just want to know
because there's other people doing it
they're getting a lot of views so i know
people are searching for it
so how do i you know what i mean how do
we navigate that you know
yes well i just brought up my friend uh
mike and catherine these are dear
friends of mine
and um they have a countertop
business so so i want you to just know
that there's a market
in all things construction and building
and roofing
and all of those things so uh mike now
is at uh
700 000 subscribers on his channel and
you'll notice he's just teaching
how he's doing it right it's not like
some special thing he's doing he
literally is like
here's how i make this countertop
so uh your question was you know should
i keep
is it is let me ask you actually your
question is
is this viable is there a market what
give me an actual like
pinpointed question yeah so i need
i know it's viable i know it's
searchable content
um it's just there's there's other
there's not a lot of other channels
doing it so i think
i mean i have my answer i just um
yeah i guess i don't know maybe i'm just
putting the card ahead of the horse here
a little bit but
um i don't know maybe maybe even
offering up your
your opinion on trade specific channels
that would be
um well first alex i just want to say i
just want to applaud you
for being a business owner who sees the
new way of marketing
right like i'll bet there's like no one
in your space right now
that literally is like you know what we
should do we should start a youtube
channel
so i want to applaud you as a craftsman
as a
as per as a person that doesn't come
from like wanting to know about cameras
and microphones and live streaming like
i understand that this is something
totally outside of the field you're in
but this is a viable marketing channel
so first off i just want to applaud you
for stepping into this space
because this isn't an easy space to step
into when you're already working a
full-time job helping people growing a
business doing all those things so first
off
let's just everyone at think marketing
applaud alex for stepping into this
i personally do believe that trademen
style
channels are actually going to be the
next movement
inside of youtube why do i say that
because people
are searching for answers and you
have a skill that can help them learn
something right so like i need to
replace my roof
cheapest roof replacement should i be
doing is it called st
what's it what's the style of roofing
that you do what's it called
standing seam standing seam stitching
metal roofing so that's the other thing
understanding what they're asking
you know um how to know if you're
getting ripped off by a roofing quote
like
there's so many questions when someone's
gonna replace their
roof or build a house that is a huge
investment and so they're spending time
doing research
trying to figure out the answers is this
the thing that i like is this the thing
that i like
was this cost right you know am i
trusting the right person all these
different things
so i personally believe that this is a
channel
um that that actually could for sure get
traction
and here's the thing also alex you don't
need a million subscribers to succeed
with this
i want you to know that you don't need a
million subscribers to
to succeed with this i think about my
friend uh roger
yeah i'm just gonna say roger i see
y'all watching lots of his stuff
yeah i love him a plumber and it's
applying what roger's doing and plumbing
to what you're doing in roofing and a
lot of times too
like i mean this is a sick setup that
roger's doing he's invested in what he's
doing this is a
uh he's a high level creator now but
like
this one here 11 months ago 2.5 million
real plumbing real plumber tries awful
plumbing hacks
like i would think about what is
happening
in your world you know your world so
what's happening
in your world that you could apply
a video to now you're just getting
started so you are in
the first year which is all about
experimenting and we want you to
experiment in obscurity to prepare you
for popularity so this is the time where
the video quality doesn't matter
this is the time where i'm going to just
find the keyword research that people
are typing in
so if we go to um if we go to youtube
again right and we type in like uh
um best roofs for homes
that's okay now let me see best roofs
for now look at all these things
sheds hot climates snow
right so your perspective because i'm
i'm constantly
using the the specific terminology
but then you know consumer terminology
is different
so yeah yeah and this is what we call
the curse of knowledge alex this is the
curse of knowledge
you know that it's called a stem seam
roof i
would have no clue what a roof is a roof
is a roof
this one's pretty because it's tan this
one's pretty because
it's metal i don't even know if that's
actually metal or is it
sheep do i rock or what you like does
that make sense so your job
is to educate me on what i need
it's called the chocolate covered carrot
i'm gonna type in the word roof
i want you to own the word roof alex
every video you're making
has the word roof in it because that's
what you're gonna
cipher people into why you believe that
roofing with this style roof is the best
way
does that make sense yeah and i mean
you're going to reach more people going
for consumers
as opposed to me educating or i mean
could it be could it be like a broad
kind of spectrum instead like
educating the trades person themselves
just
educating yes education 100 that's what
market you're in now you are in
the online education space you're going
to take the
knowledge that you have about the craft
that you've done for years and years and
years
you know it's the right thing for this
target market so you're gonna just
own that uh keyword all the time
that's where you're going for so if i go
here if i just show you here right best
roof four
look at this metal roof versus shingle
roof yeah
i don't know you're like you could make
that video two years ago look at this
250 000 views there's a market for this
right 41 000 views 29
000 views so there's for sure market oh
man look it
remember this this old house that's from
like
oh yeah they're staying out there it's
like the new
the new this old house
yeah the what i get stuck in though is
that oh there's
okay so there's two channels i see all
the time right now i'm like okay those
two
two channels own this thing so you know
bow out kind of thing so i get that in
my head but i know it's not true and
it's hard to
skirt those thoughts sometimes right but
100
and i just want to i just really want to
speak into you alex how long have you
been doing this for
oh god a month no no i mean how long
you've been roofing for oh roofing 15
16 years how many people have said thank
you so much for doing this
oh yeah it's um they they're just blown
away a lot a lot most of the time right
they did it we didn't know we could do
that with
uh with sheet metal right so yeah
so here's what i want you to take uh
those two ones that show up all the time
your goal is friendly competition
but your goal is to be just like them
who says you can't be
i believe that if you've got the
experience if you've got the heart of a
servant if you are someone who
wants to help other people and sees the
new way of marketing alex you can do
this
i want you to write down i can do this
i will until and i do
know what i'm talking about write those
things down i want you to look at that
often because
just because you're going from offline
to online
they just got here sooner that's all and
it's proof of concept
that it works and so i want you to
double down
on just the time that you're spending
creating content i want you to double
down on the
focused attention that you have to
serving this new audience which is going
to be your online audience okay
and i want you to double down on taking
the
the blinders putting the blinders on and
saying
okay cool man you do you've got this
roofing insights great job roofing
insights we're friendly competitors now
i'm your online
competitor and i'm going to give you a
run for your money i don't care if your
production value is better than mine
my content is better than yours that's
what i that's like
attitude i want you to go into with it
and i want you to just
double down and double down and double
down and stay connected to us here at
think media
because i think one of the things that i
love about our community
is that we are an encouraging and
empowering community here at think
for all types of creators not just the
young millennials who want to make
awesome youtube videos about their life
traveling around the world on their
points but for like
real business owners who want to
actually make a difference
in not just their lives but leave legacy
for their children you hear me alex
oh yeah yeah it's like it's the
potential
i mean this is this is where it's going
this is where we're headed
yeah and you and there's a race you my
friend
you're ahead of the game like you might
see these other two guys
you are a head of the game youtube
is only getting better people
understanding these new skills like
understanding video understanding
marketing understanding what you've
already tapped into
man you're you are actually light years
ahead of your industry
so i can't wait to see what happens next
week i'm not too late yeah
yeah you're in it awesome alex thank you
so much thanks so much thank
you and i'll see you in the future right
on awesome
wow what a way to end the think
marketing live
show if you are in an industry where you
feel
like shoot could this work online man
what i love about what alex just said
is there's someone already doing this
that to me those are the words i want to
hear because if someone else is doing it
it means i can do it too so
here's what i need you to write down
think marketing live
i can i am and i will
i can do this if you're saying i can't
if you're saying who am i if you're
saying i i what what is it
i can't figure this out i can't be like
that guy if you're saying that
that's not what we say here we say i can
do this we say
i am i am someone who has made a
difference
he just told me he's done this for 15
years
i mean hello i'm going to trust the guy
that's on her for 15 years over the guy
who's just
learning how to roof you know so i can
i am and i will i will until
i will figure out how to make great
content i will figure out how to make
good thumbnails i will figure out
how to reach a new audience on
line think marketing we are here for you
i'm so pumped for the future we've got
some amazing content coming up
but i want to remind you that if you've
not yet registered
for the think master class you can go
right here
we've got one day until this master
class is
live again this is a brand new master
class you can go here
you click this button you enter in your
information and you are going to be
registered for our brand new live class
that's going to be happening
on saturday we know you're working we
know you've got a day job
so we made it on a saturday for you so
that you can
join us at 10 a.m pacific standard time
1pm eastern
to learn the three strategies for how to
win
on youtube we share why we're qualified
to be teaching this
and you just go here save your seat and
that's how you can get access to our
free
one hour class that's going to be
happening this week if you
happen to be watching this on the replay
and you're like shoot i missed the class
we always have a new class ready for you
to register for so we are always in the
business
of giving you the latest information
happening on youtube
so if you missed this class don't worry
go to that same website
because we'll have a future class ready
for you to take
on your time thank you so much for
watching this video if you got value out
of it hit the like button
subscribe if you have not subscribed yet
and if you want to check out another
video on our channel here or
if you want to listen to the think
marketing podcast you can check that out
on the screen
right now my name is heather torres i am
your host here
and that felt really professional thanks
so much for watching and i'll catch you
next time bye